[Musique]
j'avais vu et avec lui ses longues
soirées nous nous sommes parfois croisé
dans le couloir passez moi au nous
tenions pas de grandes conversations il
avait toujours été son ami jamais bien
alors bonjour bonsoir c'est tout autre
chose j'en conviens mais tu ne peux
imaginer bien que ça me faisait quelques
secondes de bavardages et je me sentais
comme réchauffer puis il a pris
l'habitude d'entrer ici il fut très bon
pour moi d'une manière loyale
désintéressée je ne cherche pas
d'excusés d'un jeu je t'explose les
faits tels qu'ils se sont réellement
produits ce qui s'est passé ensuite par
témoin ce fut une véritable union avec
ses bons et ses mauvais jours
une union digne par cette totale tu vois
tu as quitté n'épouse que tu ne
connaissait pas encore et tu retrouves
une femme notons que tu me reconnais pas
[Musique]
ce soir anny duperey ne jouait pas pour
les spectateurs du théâtre michel
mais pour jean chevrin son ancien
professeur du conservatoire de rouen et
quelques-uns de ses camarades de coupe
annie et rouennaise et chaque lundi le
théâtre michel faisant relâche elle
vient passer la journée chez sa grand
mère rue saint-patrice anny duperey a
été mon élève pendant deux ans à la
classe d'art dramatique du conservatoire
de rouen à ces 2 quad est entré
brillamment à la quasi unanimité au
conservatoire national d'art dramatique
de paris en compagnie de son camarade
patrick chesnais dans la classe de rené
simon jacques carpentier et patrick
verte n'est pas là on était aussi eu au
centre d'apprentissage d'art dramatique
de la rue blanche où ils poursuivaient
encore leurs études qu annie duperey
était engagée par jean meyer pour jouer
le principal et seul rôle féminin de la
pièce que jean meyer montée précisément
au théâtre michel
pour inaugurer sa nouvelle direction ne
m'a pas étonné
anny duperey alors nommé annie le gras
aux conservateurs de rouen father ted en
effet des qualités exceptionnelles et
pendant les deux ans qu'elle a passés à
la classe d'art dramatique elle n'a
cessé de faire l'unanimité quant à ses
possibilités de carrière professionnelle
quant à l'intér su à la quasi-unanimité
aux conservateurs de paris également
tous les nombres du jury m'ont assuré
que ses qualités étaient tout à fait
exceptionnel à nu du père et vous
portiez il ya quelques semaines encore
le nom d'amy le gras pourquoi avez vous
choisi ce pseudonyme d'anny duperey
c'est d'abord j'étais assez embarrassé
sur le choix même ceux de vue j'ai
imaginé pas mal de noms que nous eûmes
ayant m'a demandé tout simplement de
chercher dans l'assam dix ans j'ai tout
de suite pensé à grand mère je vais
demander alors à la tente à l'eurostand
si habits très jeune a fait preuve de ce
don spectaculaire à l'événement pour les
fermer
vraiment que je voulais pas prendre
d'initiatives moi même je les ai emmenés
au centre d'orientation professionnelle
et là on lui a conseillé de suivre des
cours d'art dramatique
j'étais assez surpris d'ailleurs mme
quoique très jeune les bénéfices mans
aimait jouer du bach lyonnais c'est ce
que touche au théâtre elle a fréquenté
l'école des beaux-arts à l'être saint
maclou de rouen
et qu'est ce qui l'intéressait plus
particulièrement dans cette forme de
travail
moi j'étais plus porté vers la peinture
j'avais beaucoup la facture et surtout
tout ce qui touchait la lumière même le
dessin des éclairages spéciaux j'ai
essayé de rendre salle en tant qu'ami un
mouvement et vous n'avez jamais
fréquenté d'établissements secondaires
mais ainsi j'ai pu j'ai été trés
mentionne bien d'ailleurs au collège
camille saint saëns non ça ça marchait
beaucoup moins bien alors aussi à 10 ans
si je fais de la danse et je crois que
c'est ça qui m'a porté vers le théâtre
j'avais décidé en faisant de la danse de
fer par la danse parce que c'était trop
dur mais à mes yeux au terrain n'importe
lequel mais quelque chose qui soit sur
scène
et puis quand je suis entré dans sa
toile monsieur cheval la petite est
décisif et quel est le rôle du temps
très votre destin que rose qui vous
entraînent plus actuellement un rôle
moderne que j'adorerais jouer vraiment
c'est une drôle de concours en moderne
d'ailleurs c'est une grande fille toute
simple
j'aimerais jouer ce rôle en entier
ce fils watts est celle d'une grande
jeune fille toute simple qui règlent pas
il semble que paris soit prêt à
l'adopter bien des rouennais va en
réjouir
[Musique]